hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome attacking or better yet
counter-attacking game uh from the 1938
uh nord like tournament that was played
in netherlands it's rudolf spielman
versus paul kerris and i'm showing this
game as today is
years since the birth of
the great paul kerrish also known as the
always second paul kerris
and
i i thought about a lot of different
games but this one has always been one
of my favorite
games he played and one of the reasons
is probably uh maybe it's the first one
that i saw that he played it was uh
featured in the old
chess master series on on
pc i think it's the the grand master
edition yeah the chess master 9 grand
master edition or something like that uh
where we're just george waiting would
explain how to counter attack in chess
and this is a a beautiful game to really
understand the
just the notion of the counter attack in
chess because you could approach this
position
uh in in many different ways but the way
uh paul here does it it's just you know
a very human
uh so that being said let's check it out
i don't think uh
either spielman or kerris need any
further
uh introduction as they are both very
well known but it's basically a clash of
the old guard versus the new up and
coming players scarce being the
new up and coming player here very young
and spielman being a member of the the
old guard with boglywu and tartakover
and you know many of the old masters so
let's check it out and see and also a
spillman known as a brilliant brilliant
attacker himself uh
he of course
always likes to create a fire on the
board so here spillman with the white
pieces opens with e4 akeres goes for the
french defense we have e6 we have d4 d5
and now knight to c3 so a normal french
defense
knight to f6 and now e5 advancing the
pawn here the shine it's variation going
after the knight knight after d7 uh
preparing c5 and as black will try to
under undermine the center from the
flank uh white advances the f pawn to uh
additionally support the center so here
we have c5
and nowadays knight to f3 is what uh we
would play but um
d captures on c5 was it was fine in
those days uh and now uh knight to c6
keras doesn't uh
rush in in recapturing the pawn because
you can't really defend that b4 is
impossible and well there's just no no
no way to defend this pawn so here a
three archbillon prepares to play b4 to
defend the c5 pawn and only now keras
captures it we've queen to g4
uh putting pressure on this spawn
and even though this uh line is still
kind of playable many many better lines
were found for white so you will not see
this very very often in modern chess so
here g6
preventing the g7 pawn from being
captured and knight to f3 now we have a6
now akira's prepares to advance on the
queen side and now bishop to d3 uh we
have b5 now advancing on the queen side
and uh spielman the great attacker that
he is uh of course knows the value of uh
pawn to be for push so he he does that
exactly and now bishop there are a
couple of games where bishop to e7 was
played but here we have bishop to a7 and
it is as of move 11 that this position
has never been reached again so here
what do you play well uh you could
continue by just you know uh
continuing development you still have to
develop your bishop you hit still have
to decide whether you're going to castle
queen set or kingside or or whatnot for
for the moment king said castling isn't
allowed uh so we might want to attend to
that somehow maybe bring the knight here
maybe c3 maybe block with knight here
then castle uh many different ways to
play this uh but here uh he strikes with
a4 and this is a little bit weird
because uh well uh you leave your b for
pawn hanging but okay you want to create
some some trouble here and now okay uh
keras could go for knight captures on b4
and it's perfectly fine for black for
example a captures on b5 and now knight
c5 and it's really questionable uh how
white will get out of this one uh yes
okay you're threatening for example
knight captures here followed by knight
to c to check winning the rook but let's
say king e2 you sidestep all of this and
now what do you play let's say d4 you
chase away the knight knight to the e4
already uh you know it's complete
madness on the board and this is not the
the kind of chess charis wanted to play
so here cares just chased away the queen
with h5 we have queen to g3 and now
queen to e7
uh and now uh the position is well
pretty pretty crazy uh charis can still
capture this b4 pawn it's uh is just a
weakness in the position and the
spielman could continue with some like a
captures on b5 or he could offer a queen
trade with queen to g5 but he decided to
stay true to himself uh you know he
doesn't want to go against his nature
and he plays f5 another crazy attacking
move so first he goes b for a4 now f5
just advancing pawns on both sides of
the board and this was 1938 before uh
you know neural networks made it this uh
cool uh so uh it's a it's a position
where black has many great moves and i'm
sure you guys already see a couple of
them but just for for fun feel free to
pause the video and try to find the move
keras played uh as it's uh just a really
really uh human move to play and it
really shows how white's uh white's
attacking move uh will simply not to do
uh so while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding some uh
you know normal moose queen captures on
b4 or h4 or g captures on f5 but the
move keras plate is actually bishop back
to b8 and this is uh if you always think
about you know uh the strongest movies
with the knight back you will also find
these uh moves with the bishop back and
now by playing f5 what white actually
did is he weakened the e5 pawn with the
b4 pawn already weak this is uh
well not all that uh not all that easy
to pull off so now how do you continue
this with white uh wha what can you play
here well here uh f captures on g6 was
played there's really no good way to
defend the e5 pawn as it's attacked
three times and now carrot just goes
knight captures on the uh on e5 and now
uh what do you play here uh strongest
for white is queen g5 you offer a queen
trade and uh
after this gets traded off for example
captures we're gonna capture on f7 with
check knight captures bishop captures uh
it's still not all that great for white
we can capture on b4 here and now let's
say captures on b5 we're going to play
90 captures knight captures and bishop
e5 now attack the knight and it's uh
well black is up a pawn but his position
is also much better very very active and
white would not have a lot of fun
playing this
so instead after knight d captures an e5
we have g captures on f7 queen captures
on f7 and now knight to g5 attacking the
the queen here so queen to f6 an
excellent square for the queen not only
are you threatening to move the knight
to expose the queen to the bishop but
also once this e5 knight moves you will
also
expose this diagonal so this is the the
the power of keras in its fullest
rook to f1 now attacking the queen and
offering well basically offering the
exchange uh but now keras goes knight to
g4 and now everything is attacked this
is attacked this is attacked or rather
the queen is attacked the knight here is
attacked with check if the knight moves
then the rook is attacked so what do you
play here uh if you just go for the
trade rook captures an f6 then we
capture on g3 h captures knight captures
on f6 we've won the exchange where we're
very happy with our position so instead
after knight to g4 we have queen to f3
sidestepping this bishop and also now uh
just uh you know really staying true to
your nature spielman as a natural
attacker gives up a full knight here
with check so he can start attacking
with queen to f7 maybe and uh
try and create something so keras goes
for this queen captures on c3 with check
king to d1 and now he can even grab a
rook here and while grabbing a rook is
perfectly fine again it could be a
little bit dangerous queen captures an
a1 queen to f7 check we're gonna move
the king knight captures with czech
bishop captures queen captures and now
with the you know the the light square
bishop ready the rook ready to jump into
the game if the queen leaves the back
rank maybe we can even throw in a bishop
to g5 check
it looks dangerous even though you can't
play this there's no reason to do it
we've just grabbed a piece on c3 we just
go back queen to g7 and now what can
pilman do
he's down material
is there any compensation in the
position he tries queen to e2 to do some
damage here on the e6 square but not
rook to f8 very very simple again not
going for that a1 rook because you don't
want to over complicate you you you know
you have a winning position so here uh
if you go for knight captures and e6
it's nothing special just rook captures
on f1 and now the queen has to move away
from the defense of the knight on e6 so
instead uh uh spielman just captured an
f8 we have king captures knight captures
with czech forking the king and the
queen but luckily we have our bishop so
queen captures on e6 and now knight to
f2 with check even this not capturing
the rook but first we want to eliminate
as many attackers as possible
so now if you go king d2 then bishop to
f4 is just uh extremely strong so here
king the e1 was played
knight captures on d3 we have c captures
on d3 and here uh rudolph schwilman
resigned and moved 26 without even
allowing uh
keras to uh to play his next move even
though now he would probably capture the
rook on a1
so uh the thing is okay now you capture
on a1 let's say queen captures on c6
you're going to move the rook and you're
up a full rook so of course completely
winning rook to e7 check is coming and
there's not much white can do about this
you can't move the bishop uh so there
there's nothing you can do
so uh this is the game i chose uh there
were a lot of good candidates uh
at the show because uh
paul kerris just has so many amazing
games uh but i decided to show this one
as i remember when i first saw this game
it really
uh you know made me think about uh how
uh how i'm playing chess uh wrong and
poorly sometimes or where rather most of
the times uh when you can play a move
here for example after f5 you can you
know just slow down play bishop to b8
and ask why what are you doing what is
what is it this b4 uh a4f5 madness i
mean it's not going to work just bishop
to b8 and your entire position just
collapses
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it a nice birthday present for
from paul cares for his 106th birthday i
hope you guys enjoyed that uh i would
like to thank thomas vettel uh martin
schweller dylan holloway pat coppinger
and mother eastman for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the chess world
uh thank you i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day